you
removal of the appendix called
appendectomy is performed when
appendicitis is suspected right lower
abdominal pain fever and elevated
white-blood-cell count are common
symptoms and signs of appendicitis which
usually occurs when a blockage develops
between the appendix and the intestine
this leads to infection swelling and
distension if the appendix is not
removed it can lead to a
life-threatening perforation or rupture
the only treatment for appendicitis is
appendectomy which is almost always
performed on an emergency basis
newer laparoscopic techniques require
only tiny keyhole incisions or puncture
wounds which generally result in a
shorter recovery period
before your surgery an intravenous line
will be started appendectomies are done
under general anesthesia which will put
you to sleep for the duration of the
operation a breathing tube will be
temporarily inserted through your mouth
and into your throat to help you breathe
during the operation a catheter may also
be placed in your bladder to drain your
urine
an uncomplicated laparoscopic
appendectomy usually takes between 20
and 30 minutes to gain access to your
appendix your surgeon will use sharp
instruments called trocars to create
three small holes or ports through your
abdominal wall these ports are usually
located at your navel or umbilicus and
in the upper right and lower left
quadrant of your abdomen carbon dioxide
gas will then be pumped through the
umbilical port to puff up your abdomen
so its contents can be viewed more
easily next your surgeon will insert the
laparoscope through the umbilical port
images from its camera are projected
onto a video monitor in the operating
room your surgeon will carefully examine
the inside of your abdomen confirming
that your appendix is red swollen and
needs removal at this point your surgeon
will pass surgical instruments through
the other two ports grasp the appendix
separated from the intestine drop it
into a specimen bag and remove the
specimen bag through one of the ports
after your appendix has been safely
removed your surgeon will instill warm
sterile saltwater through one of the
ports into the abdomen to cleanse the
abdominal cavity and remove any traces
of infection the salt water is then
suctioned out before removing the
laparoscope your surgeon will take one
final look around for areas of bleeding
or other damage when the laparoscope is
removed a port valve is left in place
briefly to allow all the carbon dioxide
to escape from the abdomen finally the
keyhole incisions are closed with
sutures or staples and covered with
bandages
at the conclusion of the surgery your
breathing tube and catheter will be
removed and you will be taken to the
recovery area for monitoring where you
will be given pain medication as needed
when you are able to drink liquids your
intravenous line will be removed most
patients can leave the hospital within
24 hours